nos dicen que r quintos es igual a 8
decimos y queremos encontrar aquí es
igual r
además nos dan esta recta numérica como
apoyo donde colocaron 8 decimos esto
tiene sentido ya que entre 0 y 1
dividieron en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
saltos iguales y en este punto tenemos 8
de estos 10 altos iguales entre 0 y 1
por lo tanto este punto es 8 decimos
además etiquetaron un quinto para
nosotros entonces podemos decir que si
sólo observamos estas marcas gruesas en
morado tenemos 0 1
345 tenemos cinco saltos iguales cada
uno de estos saltos morados es un quinto
tiene sentido que nuestro primer salto
nos lleve hasta un quinto y podemos
observar que esto es equivalente a dos
de los décimos un quinto es igual a
todos decimos pero cuántos quintos es lo
mismo que ocho decimos pausa el vídeo e
intenta encontrar la respuesta
bien este es un quinto y si avanzamos
otro quinto llegaremos a todos quintos
si avanzamos otro quinto llegaremos a
tres quintos y si avanzamos otro quinto
llegaremos a cuatro quintos justo aquí
podemos ver que cuatro quintos es
equivalente a ocho décimos y esto es
cierto porque además observamos que un
quinto es lo mismo que dos décimos
entonces cuatro quintos a ser
equivalente a ocho de esos décimos
podemos verlo claramente por aquí y por
lo tanto r es igual a cuatro cuatro
quintos es igual a otro decimos entonces
r es igual a cuatro
bien hagamos otro ejemplo infracción es
equivalente al punto a pausa el vídeo e
intentarlo por tu cuenta bien primero
veamos dónde se encuentra el punto a
para ir de 0 a 1 tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis saltos iguales por lo
tanto cada uno de estos saltos es un
sexto si damos un salto desde cero
llegamos a un sexto dos sextos tres
sextos cuatro sextos y cinco sextos pero
tenemos cuatro sextos en nuestras
opciones
no es una de nuestras opciones por lo
tanto tenemos que encontrar una fracción
equivalente a 4 sextos así que vayamos
opción por opción en la primera tenemos
a 5 sextos y muy claramente podemos ver
que 5 sextos está aquí en nuestra recta
numérica
entonces en definitiva está en un lugar
distinto que 4 sextos así que podemos
cancelar esta opción que hay de las
otras opciones vamos a pensar en ellas
cuatro quintos contra cuatro sextos
pueden ser equivalentes si tenemos
cuatro de cinco contra cuatro de seis no
sé algo no está bien aquí voy a poner
una línea curva ya que algo no se siente
bien de esta opción si tenemos cuatro de
cinco saltos iguales o cinco secciones
iguales esto es lo mismo que cuatro de
seis secciones iguales bueno si
dividimos en seis secciones iguales cada
sección es un poco más pequeña que si
dividimos en cinco secciones iguales y
si tenemos cuatro de ellas entonces
tendremos un valor distinto de hecho si
lo pensamos de esta manera creo que
podemos sentirnos más seguros de que
esta no es la opción correcta así que la
cancela haremos que hay de seis cuartos
bueno ya sabemos que cuatro cuartos es
lo mismo que uno por lo tanto seis
cuartos va a estar más allá de 1 así que
en definitiva no estará en el punto y
por lo tanto también podemos cancelarla
y bueno podríamos decir entonces debe de
ser la opción de pero vamos a
asegurarnos de que es la correcta como
se ven dos tercios bueno vamos a dividir
esta recta numérica entre cero y uno en
tercios en tres secciones iguales aquí
tenemos al cero y tenemos un tercio dos
tercios y por último tres tercios que es
lo mismo que uno ya tenemos tres
secciones iguales por lo tanto este de
aquí es un tercio si damos otro salto de
un techo llegamos a dos tercios y cuando
llegamos a uno por supuesto tenemos tres
tercios que podemos decir que es lo
mismo que seis sextos entonces el punto
a que está justo aquí en efecto es igual
a dos tercios puedes ver que cada salto
de un tercio es lo mismo que dos sextos
por lo tanto tiene sentido que cuatro
sextos sean lo mismo que dos
o que dos tercios es igual a 4 sextos
así que elegiremos esta opción